[Alkış]
[Müzik]
duyduğunuz Bu sesler gerçek bir video
oyunundan efektif sesler değil Vietnam
ve İkinci Dünya Savaşı'ndan kaydedilmiş
sesler
2021 yılında evlerinden ülkelerinden
kaçmak zorunda kalan insanların sayısı
rekor düzeylere ulaştı son 5 yılda yeni
ya da eski en az 15 çatışma dünya
çapında milyonlarca insan için tarif
edilmez büyüklükte trajedi ve acıyı
beraberinde getirdi
binlerce aile evlerini terk etmek ve
ülkelerinden
ayrılarak her şeye geride bırakmak
zorunda kalıyorlar Sizin gibi insanlar
Benim gibi insanlar
her iki saniyede bir kişi cinsiyeti deli
dini
ırkı politik görüşü ya da bir toplumsal
grubun üyesi olduğu için ya da
çatışmalardan dolayı yerinden ediliyor
bu 18 dakikalık konuşmayı
tamamlayıncaya kadar yaklaşık 400 kişi
bu etkinlik tamamlanıncaya kadar da
bütün dünyada yaklaşık 5.000 kişi zorla
yerinden edilmiş olacak
Uzmanlar iç savaşların çatışmaların sel
kuraklık gibi doğal afetlerin artmasıyla
yer değiştirmelerin çok daha fazla
artacağını Bu daha başlangıç sözleriyle
ifade ediyorlar
Ben Ayşegül Yalçın Eriş bugün konuşmamda
Size iki mesaj vermek istiyorum İlk
mesajım
sığınma talebi bir halktır
Ankara Üniversitesi hukuk Fakültesi'ni
kazanıp kaydımı yaptırdığım zaman
Aslında okulda ne okuyacağıma ve bunu
neden okuyacağımı neden öğreneceğime
dair hiçbir fikrim yoktu Çok da iyi bir
öğrenci sayılmazdım bu Çiftlik
işlerinden öğrencilerden birisiydi
aslında
son sınıfta İnsan Hakları Hukuku dersi
tahmin edebileceğiniz gibi insan hakları
nedir diye başladı
insan hakları
sanırım Evet insan hakları nedir diye
başladı konu ağır bir konuydu ama
sevgili hocamız kendine has bir ısıtla
çok basit demişti tanımı demişti ki Her
insanın kendi öyküsünü yaşayabilme hakkı
vardır Arkadaşlar bu tanımla Ben adeta
çarpıldım ama hiç merak etmeyin hemen
kendime geldim günlük hayatıma devam
ettim unuttum utanımı orada Sonra
üniversite bitti üniversite bittikten
sonra daha popüler ve daha çok nispeten
daha çok para kazandırdığını düşündüğüm
olanlarda çalışmaya o kalktık yapmaya
devam ettim sonra yaklaşık 20 yıl sonra
Eşimin işi nedeniyle şehir değiştirmemiz
gerekti Ben 40 yaşındaydım O zaman bu
şehir değişikliğini bir fırsat gibi
değerlendirerek bir vesile olarak gördüm
ve o güne kadar hep gönüllü destek
verdim kadınlar ve göçmenlerle ilgili
kendi öyküsünü yaşama hakkına erişememiş
olan kimselere destek olmayı denemeye
karar verdim bunu bu fırsat olarak
kullandım Ve şimdi değilse ne zaman
dedim kendi kendime
Birkaç ay sonra da takip edeceğim ilk
dosya ile karşı karşıya oturuyordum
okula gitmeleri yasaklanan kız çocukları
için Afganistan'da evinde gizlice bir
okul açan Afganistan'da bir kadın
karşında oturuyordum Bu kadının evinde
açtığı gizli okul Taliban taraftarları
fark edilmiş Önce evi yıkılmıştı direnip
vazgeçmeyince de o zaman 2-3 yaşında
olan kız çocuğu kaçırılmıştı oraya
şehrin ileri gelenleri Eee girince ileri
gelenleri girdikten sonra kız çocuğunu
ancak afganistan'ı terk etmesi koşuluyla
geri almıştı Bu kadın kendi hikayesini
yaşamı hakkında erişemeyen milyonlarca
kız çocuğuyla beraber karşımda
oturuyordu
mülteci göçmen kadınlar ve kız çocukları
ile çalışmaya benim hikayeme ben böyle
başladım
Birleşmiş Milletler göç Örgütüne göre
uluslararası göçmen sayısı son 50 yılda
önemli bir artış gösterdi 2020 yılında
doğduğu ülke dışında yaşayanların sayısı
281 milyona ulaşmıştı bugünkü sayıyı
söylemiyorum yani söyleyemiyorum 2022
henüz açıklanmadığı için ama
zannediyorum 300'ü 350'yi geçmiş durumda
şu anda
bu sayı yine 1970 yılında tahmin
edilenin 3 katından daha fazla şu anda
Birleşmiş Milletler mülteci Örgütüne
göre ise 2022 yılının ilk 6 ay
itibariyle
yerinden edilenlerin sayısı zorla yerini
denilenlerin sayısı 103 milyonu
geçmiştir bu sayı daha geçen sene Yani 6
ay önce 89 milyondu şu anda dünyada her
77 kişiden bir kişi zorla yerinden
edilmiştir durumda
Türkiye Yaklaşık 4 milyon yerden edilmiş
kişi ile dünyada en fazla sığınmacının
bulunduğu ülke Türkiye sırasıyla
Kolombiya Almanya Pakistan ve Uganda
takip ediyor
aralarında kadınların çocukların
engellilerin Yaşlıların da bulunduğu
milyonlarca sığınmacı ve mülteci
samın aksine mülteci nüfusunun
yüzde yetmişini kadınlar ve çocuklar
oluşturuyor yine tüm dünyada
Dünya nüfusunun %30'unu çocuklar
oluştururken bu oran mülteci
popülasyonunda 18 yaş altı için %41'e
ulaşmış durumda
bir yandan da şöyle değerlendirmek
gerekiyor galiba zorunlu sebeplerle
ülkelerin terk eden kadınlar ve çocuklar
çeşitli saldırı şiddet ve tehlikelerle
karşı karşıya kalıyor
yansıda gördüğünüz National Geographic
dergisi kapandı portresi yer alan Afgan
kızı savaştan kaçan Afgan mültecilerin
ikonik bir simgesi ikonik bir görüntüsü
haline gelmişti ismi 17 yıl boyunca
bilinmeyen Afgan kızının fotoğrafı Steve
tarafından Pakistan'da peşe var
yakınlarında Bir Mülteci kampında
çekiliyor
1985 yılında kapağında Bu fotoğrafla
yayınlanan basılan National geografik
dergisi şimdiye kadar tanınmış en çok
tanınmış nesne coğrafik dergisi
kapaklarından biri Afgan kızının
gözlerindeki korku ve Umut hepimizi
Derinden etkileyeni bir yandan da devam
ediyor
Sovyetler Birliği'nin afganistan'ı
bombalaması sırasında Afgan kızla
annesini kaybediyor 6 yaşındayken babası
ve kardeşleri ile beraber Çetin kış
koşullarına rağmen dağları aşarak
pakistan'a ulaşıyor ve Bir Mülteci
kampı'na sığınıyor sonra 13-14 ya da 15
yaşındayken kimse tam olarak yaşında
bilmediği için söyleyemiyorum evleniyor
Neslihan 2002 yılında tekrar bulana
kadar Afgan kızının adı bilinmiyor
Afgan kızı kendi ünlü fotoğrafını o
zamana kadar hiç görmemiş ve yüzünün
dünya çapında ünlü olduğunu bilmiyor
yıllarca da ününden habersiz
ismi şerbet Gülhan
1985 Nation Geographic dergisi kapağı
ile ünlenen Afgan şerbet Güral 2016
yılında Pakistan'da Sahte kimlik
nedeniyle sınır dışı ediliyor şerbet Gül
ağ çocuklarımı eğitmek için bir kimliğe
ihtiyacım vardı diyor
35 yıl boyunca kendisi ve çocukları en
temel hakkı olan kimliğe dair
erişememişti bakışları hala delice hala
korku ve umut dolu
mülteci kadınların ve çocukların
tehlikelerden korunması ve eşit haklara
sahip olması için hemen harekete
geçmemiz gerekiyor Bu hareketin ilk
adımı sığınma hakkının uluslararası
sözleşmelerle kabul edilen ve korunan
bir hak olduğunu görünür kılmaktan ve
böylece sığınma hakkının herkes
tarafından anlaşılmasını sağlamaktan
geçiyor
sizlere bugün paylaşacağım 2 mesajım
göçmenler göç ettikleri toplumları
güçlendirir
sahip oldukları bilgileri birbirleriyle
iletişimleri yani networkleri
zorluklarla baş etme becerileri
cesaretleri ve göç ettikleri yerde göç
ettikleri toplumların daha güçlü daha
dirençli topluluklar olmasına katkıda
bulunurlar
göçmenler Örneğin Albert Einstein Victor
Hugo Google kurucularından Sergey birin
YouTube kurucusu Steven Bob Marley
Freddie Mercury Luka modriç genç
arkadaşlarımız biliyordur illaki
futboldan Mark Saga
İlhan Omar Reşide Talip Bu kadınlar
çekoslavakyadan somali'den ve
Filistin'den ABD'ye sığınmış 3 kadın
politikacı bu üç kadın politikacı
hepsi cesaretleri cüretkarlıkları ve
liderlikleri ile bize ilham vermeye
devam ediyorlar Bu üç kadın politikacı
sığınma Hakkı dahil olmak üzere bütün
hakları eşit biçimde erişme fırsatı
verildiğinde göç ettikleri toplumlar
için neler sağlayabileceğini bize
gösteriyorlar
zor koşullara rağmen başardıklarıyla
süper güçleri olduğunu düşündüren Bu
kadınlar bu mültecilerin arasında
Aslında doğaüstü güçleriyle ünlü bir
süper kahramanı süpermen'i de eklememiz
gerekiyor Zira superman'de Bir Mülteci
Bunu ben söylemiyorum ama DC komik
söylüyor adlı tweet'te Superman bir
mültecidir diyor ve onlarla lütfen
dayanışın diyor çok özetle daha sonra
siz de Google'dan yine bir mültecinin
geliştirdiği Google'dan arayarak
bulabilirsiniz bu tamamını
Muhtemelen Superman'in hikayesini de
Hepimiz biliyoruzdur örnekte olan
gezegen kripton'da doğan bebek Call
dünyayı gönderiliyor zaten sonrası çizgi
roman tarihi
galaksiler arası ilk sığınmacı Superman
yandaki slayta
Superman'in mültecilere destek verdiği
bir macerasını görüyorsunuz yine Bunu
Google'dan görebilirsiniz
detaylı bir şekilde
Superman yeni ve özeldi onu yeni ve özel
kılan sadece süper güçleri değildi suçla
mücadele faaliyetleri dışında sosyal
adaletsizlik yolsuzluk aile içi şiddet
ve ırkçılık ve ayrımcılık ayrımcılığa
karşı da mücadele ediyordu ve karşıda
duruyordu
Süpermen'in bu kimliği hem geldiği yerin
özelliklerini hem de onu evlat edinen
yeni Ee ülkesindeki yeni gezegendeki
ebeveynlerinden oluşmuştu
Süpermen'in hikayesi yeni evini daha iyi
hale getiren bir göçmenin Nihayet
hikayesidir
Ben size bir de bugünlerde tanıştığım
bir başka süper güçleri olduğunu
düşündüren bir başka kahramandan da
bahsetmek istiyorum Bu defa gerçek bir
kahraman bu bir süpergirl ve aramızda
yaşıyor adı Rima 23 yaşında Suriye'de
Okulu bombalanıyor
arkadaşlarını kaybediyorum ama eğitimden
uzak kalmak istemediği için kendi
kendine ders çalışıyor 15 yaşında
ülkesini ve evini gerisinde bırakıp
ayrılmak zorunda kalıyor Türkiye'ye
geldiğinde bir yandan Hem bir tepsisinde
çalışmaya devam ediyor Bir yandan Türkçe
öğreniyor bir anda yabancı öğrenci
sınavına hazırlanıyor hedefi Ee savaşta
gördüğü yaralılardan çok etkilendiği
için onlara yardım etmek ve insanlar
yardımcı olmak için hedefi Doktor olmak
Hekim olmak ve tıp fakültesini kazanmak
aldığı yüksek puanla da kazanıyor
fakültesini şu anda tıp fakültesinde
okuyor limon
tıp fakültesinde okurken bir yandan da
geçici bulduğu işlerde çalışmaya devam
ediyor
kendisi ile yaptığımız görüşmede Tam
zamanlı çalışamadığı için kendisini
ailesine karşı çok mahcup hissettiğini
söylemişti Çünkü derslere katılman ve
ders çalışmam da gerekiyor dedi Riva
kendi hikayesini yazmaya devam ediyor
düşmanı tosya'ya atfedilen bir sözle
sona erdirmek istiyorum Tolstoy bütün
muhteşem hikayeler iki şekilde
gerçekleşir demiş ya bir insan yolculuğa
çıkar ya da şehre bir yabancı gelir
benim öğrendiğim tanımı ile insan
hakları ne demek olduğunu tekrar edecek
tekrar söyleyecek olursam
Rima ve diğer tüm evlerinden ayrılmak
zorunda kalanların Tolstoy'un ve sevgili
hocamın da söylediği gibi muhteşem
hikayelerini yaşama hakkını Yani insan
haklarını korumak için bugün bir
fırsatımız var şimdi
davetiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]